not suck in this show I'm inviting
myself inside the minds of some truly
unusual people as they've mastered
something I wish everyone knew about
work today procrastination and why it's
not as much of a character flaw or is
impossible to overcome as you might
think
thanks to Hilton for sponsoring this
episode
[Music]
procrastination is intentionally
delaying a task that needs to be done
even though you know it will come with
the cost instead of working you might
find yourself watching cat videos on
YouTube looking in your fridge to see if
something new has magically appeared in
the last 10 minutes or deciding your
productivity problem is that you type
too slow
then taking a typing test online to
confirm your suspicions and then taking
it over and over to get a better score
if you're like most people you first
became acquainted with procrastination
in school somewhere between 80 and 95
percent of students procrastinate and
half of them do it chronically but it
doesn't just disappear when you graduate
about 15 to 20 percent of adults or
chronic procrastinators I'm not one of
them I'm the opposite a procrastinator
someone who feels pressure to start
tests immediately and finish them ahead
of schedule although I did get sucked
into that typing test but if a task is
important I tend to get it done before
the deadline and my colleagues tell me
that can be annoying I'm constantly late
to meetings my Excuse
I was busy finishing another project
early so I'm pretty fascinated by
chronic procrastinators who live on the
opposite extreme like Douglas Adams who
wrote The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy on a typical writing day he would
sit in the bath for hours waiting for an
idea to come by the time he got out and
got dressed he often forgot the idea
which would lead him right back to the
bathtub it was so bad that he once had
his editor lock him in a hotel suite for
several weeks one that presumably only
had a shower writers are legendary
procrastinators the question is why and
Margaret Atwood has an answer unseen
myself as lazy if you're a
procrastinator you might have said the
same thing about yourself lazy slacker
undisciplined
but is margaret atwood best-selling
author of dozens of books really lazy
yeah no that's that's one of the common
myths about procrastination is just
people being lazy
fuchsias ur-wah is a psychologist in the
UK her specialty is studying
procrastination and she knows that the
root of procrastination is actually
something far sneakier than laziness
it's not about avoiding work it's about
avoiding feelings
more specifically negative emotions we
say at the core the cross nation is
about mood regulation so a task may
elicit lack of confidence feelings of
incompetency insecurity fear of failure
anxiety you put that task aside and
you've just regulated your mood now you
feel better it's like oh great I don't
have to think about anymore you know
more about this than most people do you
do still procrastinate yeah well you
know I'm human so yeah I do i do
procrastinate the classic thing for me
is you know I've got this paper to write
and I just I'm thinking that it's this
is gonna be really hard and I keep I
build it up into something that's really
huge and you know after a couple of days
of that I just kind of got right I'm
procrastinating I've just got to get on
with this
everyone procrastinates on something if
you're on top of your work there's
probably still a task you're delaying
even though you know it comes at a cost
you've got to buy a present for your
aunt did she only see once a year for
example and she tends to be really picky
and so now you're thinking huh if I make
a mistake she's just gonna give me that
look it's good this doesn't sound like a
hypothetical example I'm not gonna ask
you to name your aunt but if you still
think you're just lazy here's some proof
take a look at what you do while you're
procrastinating some of those tasks
actually take a lot of energy and effort
you'll see some you know classic chronic
procrastinators they will have the
neatest houses everything will be
organized all the dishes will be done
everything will be clean but the big
looming tasks that they're supposed to
be doing is
being done if you're actively doing
something else it's pretty clear that
you're not lazy you're avoiding a task
that stirs up negative emotions and that
can have consequences at work chronic
procrastinators are less productive than
their peers and their health suffers for
it if you're a chronic procrastinator
you have higher levels of stress you
have poor sleep quality you tend to not
exercise as much you might eat more junk
food especially because you're stressed
right
if your credit krasner you've got
difficulty regulating yourself which can
lead to depression and anxiety
they actually part off seeking help for
those mental health issues which doesn't
help either Oh No so they met a
procrastinate yes definitely people feel
guilty when they procrastinate but that
guilt doesn't operate in the same way
that it does for most people guilt can
be a motivating emotion right yeah it's
like the uma Bombeck line that guilts is
the gift that keeps on giving
yeah well for procrastinators what it
gives is more procrastination so unfair
right even if you're not a chronic
procrastinator there are certain types
of tasks that you might have a habit of
postponing might be a procrastination ik
environment because did you say
procrastinate genic yes it's an
environment that it can evoke
procrastination I am absolutely using
this as an excuse it's not me it's not
that I lack willpower this is just a
very procrastinate genic task yeah tasks
that don't give you autonomy that lack
structure and that are ambiguous is that
why so many writers struggle with
procrastination I could be because yeah
when you're writing who's telling you
what the next thing is you're supposed
to be writing right you are I mean it
brings up uncertainty about yourself it
brings up doubts about whether you know
what you're doing right we all have that
feeling from time to time you might find
yourself procrastinating to avoid
anxiety confusion or boredom whichever
your flavor of procrastination
psychology points to a couple ways to
curb it for one you can start by trying
to be a little kinder to yourself
about your past procrastination yep this
actually makes a difference our emotions
can actually change the way we view the
task instead of beating yourself up show
yourself a little compassion relieve the
guilt research reveals that after
students put off studying for an exam
those who forgive themselves are
actually less likely to procrastinate on
preparing for the next test
fuschia our colleagues have found that
it helps to remind yourself that you're
not the only one suffering from
procrastination it's part of the human
condition everyone does it on occasion
sometimes I will just sort of step back
and go yep yep I'm just being like every
other procrastinator in the flat there
right now and you're acknowledging what
you're doing accepting responsibility
for but you're not feeding back into the
negative emotions that probably put you
in that place where you wanted to
procrastinate in the first place it
turns out that self compassion is
especially hard if you're a neurotic
perfectionist the kind of person who
constantly beats yourself up for never
doing work that's good enough if that's
you you might take a cue from productive
perfectionist and stop judging your work
before you've even produced it in other
words don't criticize yourself while
you're creating try waiting until you've
finished of helping your ideas before
you worry about evaluating them that's
something Margaret Atwood advises the
waste paper basket is your friend
so go ahead say something it may be the
wrong thing but you can throw that out
and no one will ever read your dumb
thing that you've put on them Margaret
has a long history of procrastinating to
escape negative emotions I
procrastinated about starting the
Handmaid's Tale I procrastinator for
about three years I tried to write him a
more normal novel instead because I
thought it was just too bad he too bad
he really yeah I mean it doesn't seem
very badiy now but but think of when
this was it was in the early 80s yeah it
just seemed a bit too bad II Margaret
wasn't just worried that the plot was
far-fetched her fears actually kept her
from writing the book sooner you don't
know who's gonna read it you've got no
idea you don't know whether they'll like
it or not
it's not something you can anticipate or
have any control over really years ago
when asked to describe her writing
routine Margaret said she would spend
the morning procrastinating and worrying
then plunge into the manuscript in a
frenzy of anxiety around three o'clock
when it looked as though she might not
get anything done it still happens to
her sometimes scrolling around on the
news certainly can get me sucked in
luckily Margaret has come up with a
unique strategy for dealing with her
procrastination habit and it's a trick
that lines up with what some researchers
recommend I had a another name that I
grew up with and that gave me to name so
I handed double identity so Margaret
does the writing and the other one does
everything else her alter egos name is
Peggy it's a Scottish diminutive of
Margaret do you actually refer to
yourself by both identities in your head
absolutely seriously well you say what
arrangement gives me do you have
conversations between Margaret and Peggy
no they lead quite separate lives Peggy
does the laundry now there is of course
some overlap because sometimes when
Peggy's doing a laundry Margaret is
thinking about what is being written
deciding what to write is done by
Margaret deciding when to write is
sometimes a tug-of-war Margaret's dual
identity strategy isn't as strange as it
sounds
psychologists have long observed that we
have two selves the want self and the
should self your want self runs on
emotions it's drawn to whatever avoids
pain or brings pleasure in the short run
that's Margaret watching Captain
Underpants oh you'd rather me watch
watching Captain Underpants let's face
it the shed self is more concerned with
doing the right thing in the long run
that's Peggy the ordinary person who
walks the dog and needs them bran flakes
for breakfast
in the moment the want self is often
stronger no matter how hard you try to
push herself to do the work you should
be doing it's easy to get pulled into
the show you want to be binging like
maybe The Handmaid's Tale
that's the bad news the good news is
that the should self is smarter you can
outwit the want self by planning ahead
this is a second strategy for beating
procrastination that science teaches us
you don't have to worry about resisting
temptation if you remove temptation in
college my roommate Palmer was brilliant
at this whenever it was time to study
for an exam he would ask me to hide his
video games you've probably done it to
your should self puts the alarm clock
across the room at night so your want
self can't reach the snooze button in
the morning you prevent procrastination
by taking willpower out of the equation
or maybe your should self announces to
the world that you're signing off social
media so your want self won't get sucked
back in which is what Peggy does for
Margaret who loves Twitter and sometimes
posts random questions that pop up for
instance I put up a picture of a weird
mushroom and said what is this because I
couldn't find it when you're tweeting
how often does that happen while you're
writing do you actually interrupt
yourself or get destroy no I might get
distracted before I before I take the
plunge into the writing burrow but not
while I'm in it how do you prevent that
from happening is there is there a
mental firewall of sorts you turn off
for many people easier said than done
you just turn it off and that's it yes
don't go there
it can help to schedule a specific tasks
in your calendar the same way you
schedule meetings in one experiment
writers were randomly assigned to plan
daily writing sessions they were over
four times more productive and they
didn't lose any creativity even
scheduling 15 minutes a day was enough
to make some progress that's time
management you can also think about
timing management when do you
procrastinate procrastinators tend to be
night owls the start of the work day is
out of sync with their circadian rhythms
if that's you and you have the
flexibility try moving a task or you
procrastinate to later in the day when
the wants might be less tempting one of
my favorite tactics for outsmarting my
wants elf is a twist on the to-do list I
found out that Margaret does it too so
the list would include everything from
call the tree guy to you know clean the
furnace if it's not on the list it
doesn't happen that's her to-do list but
she also has a - don't list a set of
activities to avoid while working think
about your - don't list what would you
put on it when I'm working on my boring
procrastinate genic tasks like reading
contracts and proofreading articles my -
don't list includes don't play online
Scrabble don't turn on the TV unless I
already know what I want to watch and
don't scroll on social media after
posting Peggy also puts social media on
Margaret's - don't list to hold herself
accountable she makes a public
commitment
tweeting that she's signing off - right
I'm about to write goodbye that's about
going off social media for a while and
then and and reassuring people that I'm
not dead yet
or possibly disappointing them then I'm
not dead yet I can't imagine that anyone
is disappointed they would be even more
excited to hear from me if I were dead
they wouldn't be really excited that I'm
having a hard time reconciling your self
description of being lazy and
procrastinating with your enormous
productivity well just consider some
elementary math
take the number of years I've been alive
and divide and divide it by the number
of books I've written all right so you
average less than one a year yes and
some are quite short and you don't feel
like that's a lot
no it just dunno they accumulate maybe
you can start forgiving your want self
for procrastinating
maybe you'll succeed at putting some of
the should tasks on your calendar and
some wants on your - don't list still
you can't shake the feeling that if only
you had more time you could get more
done but what if the opposite is true
more on that after the break
[Music]
okay this is gonna be a different kind
of ad I played a personal role in
selecting the sponsors for this podcast
because they all have interesting
cultures of their own today we're going
inside the workplace at Hilton
[Music]
it's not uncommon for people to say my
co-workers feel like my family but I
recently met someone who takes that
sentiment to a whole new level the
Doubletree by Hilton Sonoma wine country
is my second home
everybody here is my family that's
Jessica Clingman Kern's a team member at
Hilton in October 2017 when wildfires
swept through wine country her parents
home burned down the fire just kind of
completely took over their entire
neighborhood and their house was was
gone
it's hard my brother had passed away
just a couple months prior so all of his
things around our house just a lot of
parts of our life that we'll never get
back it was devastating but after
sitting with her grief for just a moment
Jessica's sprang into action I emptied
out my boyfriend's Tahoe and put all my
camping stuff in the car and then I went
to Walmart and maxed out a credit card
with just toothbrushes and toothpaste
and deodorant and just little things for
someone who left their house at midnight
and had nothing and I just started
driving she headed to the Doubletree to
set up a makeshift relief operation a
manager provided her with a small
conference room which quickly became too
small of a conference room I think
everyone at the hotel thought I was
crazy because I was like oh I just need
a little bit more space and then they
started seeing semi trucks so my one
little room turned into ten thousand
square feet a hundred volunteers
millions of dollars in donations of the
thousands of Californians who lost their
homes several were Jessica's colleagues
that didn't stop them from volunteering
or being a part of everything either so
I could not have done it without their
support
each year Hilton CEO presents the light
and warmth the word to a dozen of their
425,000 team members it's the highest
honor in the company given the people
who embody Hilton's vision mission and
values I knew about the light and warmth
award but I never thought that I would
even be thought of experiments show that
it's not just the recipients of
recognition who end up performing better
their colleagues due to awards are not
just a powerful way to show the winners
that they're valued they're also an
important way to signal to everyone
what's valued in the culture a few
months after the relief effort
Jessica headed to a meeting where she
was surprised with a phone call it was
Hilton CEO she hadn't just been
nominated for the award she won so they
awarded me with those big obnoxious
checks but I looked at the other side
and it said $10,000 and I was like oh no
come on this is a joke where's the
camera right but as soon as it kind of
hit me like I thought how else can I
help people with this money I can
sponsor families for the holidays this
year I can donate some of this to
rebuilds one of the many people amazed
was Jessica's dad when I think back on
it you've seen all the work and caring
to Jesse put into helping the entire
community I mean that in itself makes up
for any losses that we had it's just in
my nature to help other people that's
why I love hospitality Hilton was named
fortunes number-one best company to work
for in the u.s. in both 2019 and 2020
and one of the best places to work for
millenials by the great place to work
Institute learn more at jobs Hilton comm
you
[Music]
procrastination is the opposite of
productivity it's wasting time or at
least using it freely it efficiently
we've talked about how individuals can
avoid that but I also want to know what
organizations can do upon it which might
mean thinking differently about what it
means to be productive well I think the
first question we should ask ourselves
is what is work and what is productivity
you know nowadays we say work is just a
thing you do in a hierarchical
relationship with an employer and you
get a salary you pay taxes over that and
that is what we call work meet Rutger
Bregman I'm a Dutch historian and author
and why do you feel the need to mention
that you're Dutch huh that's a good
question well maybe because the
Netherlands is the country with the
shortest working week in the world and
also we have incredibly high
productivity per hour so it's it's
actually a good of example of my thesis
that actually if you want to be more
productive
you got to work less how would you
define productivity what do you consider
a really productive day at work it
probably has something to do with time
and without put how many hours you spend
actually paying attention to your tasks
instead of scrolling on Instagram how
many boxes on your to-do list you
checked but what if you redefine
productivity my definition would be work
or being productive is just doing
something that is valuable right that is
useful I like this I think of
productivity is using your time to
accomplish things of value to you and
others whether you use your time well
depends on how much of it you have
psychologists find that being busy
having less time motivates us to finish
tasks faster
we often procrastinate less when we have
more on our plate and actually there's
some evidence that people with multiple
children are more productive at work
than people with one or none new study
suggests that parents are more absorbed
in their job tasks while at work because
they know how much they have to juggle
later at home I guess the old saying is
true if you want something done give it
to a busy person of course your ideal
solution of procrastination is not going
to be having kids or having even more
kids but this research suggests that
when you have less time to complete your
tasks or more tasks to complete in a
given time it can curb procrastination
by changing your emotions when you're
busy you're more motivated by fear and
guilts about falling behind
then whatever unpleasant feelings you
have around the task itself but when you
have a lot of free time you don't feel
that urgency to finish there's a name
for it
Parkinson's law the idea that work
contracts or expands to fill the time
available I actually experienced this
when I was working at a traditional
Dutch newspaper and I remember all those
afternoons I'm not very productive
during the afternoon you know so around
4:00 p.m. I just want to start bothering
my colleagues and making stupid jokes
Rutgers proposed what might seem like a
radical solution to those episodes of
procrastination shortening the workweek
it's not as crazy as it sounds because
the whole notion that 40 hours is a
magic number for productivity is kind of
arbitrary if you look at the history of
this it was Henry Ford already at the
beginning of the 20th century who
already find out that when he moved his
workers to a 40-hour work week they were
more productive right and he didn't do
it because he cared so much about his
employees you know he cared about his
wallet that was the reason why he did it
it was called the American Way working
less it's the American Way and actually
rutger points out that for more than a
century work weeks were getting shorter
and shorter in the mid-1800s people
often worked 70 hour weeks
then around the turn of the century
workweek started dropping from 60 to 50
hours a week and then it after the
Second World War
economist John Maynard Keynes said we'll
have a 15 hour work week in 2030 I
promise this is going to tie back to
procrastination I'm just putting it off
for a little while because I want to
know why we're working so many hours
today there are lots of possible
explanations from rising competition and
globalization and consumerism to being
obsessed with status at work to just
believing more is better
whatever the cause you'll be familiar
with what the result looks like now
probably at this moment around the globe
there are millions of people sitting in
offices just waiting browsing Facebook
sending emails to people they don't
really like writing reports that no
one's ever gonna read I think we could
easily move to a four-day three-day
workweek and be just as productive you
just squash out all the slack that's
currently in the system how many hours
do you actually work I think about 50 to
60 if you would define my work as you
know I'm I am i working right now this
work I don't know does it feel like work
are you contributing something valuable
to the world well you decide that no I
find it very hard to define you know
what work is for me
I wonder then is there is there some
degree of irony that a guy who works 50
to 60 hours a week is calling for a 15
hour work week yes it's very very ironic
oh very I know that I feel like I mean I
also I think I work more hours than you
do in a typical week and I've also
called for shorter work weeks so I part
I wanted I wanted to know that I wasn't
the only hypocrite out there but yeah
we're both crazy
exactly but I think that may be the
difference between our lives and the
policy changes we're calling for is we
choose to work this number of hours
right I I work as many hours I as I do
because I find my work enjoyable and
meaningful and what I want is for the
hundreds of millions of people who hate
their work or who find it extremely
stressful to have the freedom to work
lest if they so choose
yeah you could also frame it like this I
think that often we need to work less in
order to do more right to have more time
for the things that we really care about
we should think about productivity not
as the volume of output but as the value
of output if we're gonna do that then we
need to start measuring work in
something beyond ours which is starting
to happen leaders are beginning to
realize there's a big difference between
working long hours and doing worthwhile
work
Finland's new prime minister has spoken
in support of a four-day workweek and a
six hour work day in the u.s. Shake
Shack is trying out a four-day week for
managers at many of their locations and
recently Microsoft Japan tested the
four-day work week productivity climbed
by 40 percent there in part because of
more focused attention and in part
because they got rid of unnecessary
distractions by making meetings shorter
but my favorite example comes from
another company it has gone to the
extreme to help people use their time
more productively
even people who are chronic
procrastinators I was definitely not
Employee of the Year or anything like
that just a whole lot of procrastination
Jade Walker has struggled with
procrastination in the past maybe
because she lives in a beautiful part of
New Zealand I'm based in tech Epona
which is the suburb of Auckland it's
like a beach town are you a surfer no
I've got two little kids
so mom life is how I spend my spare time
chasing them around but at work she
found herself getting distracted by
another kind of surfing oh it's
definitely an internet safer online
shopping talking to my friends this is
really bad but I used to do a grocery
shopping online and it gets delivered
I love the efficiency of that day my
ammo bus probably wouldn't agree maybe
then she took a new job in estate
planning creating wills for people in
the hospital and for navy soldiers about
to deploy Jade's new company
- a guardian does something unusual they
offer a four-day workweek new employees
start out at five days and if they prove
their productivity in the first few
months they get to go down to four days
it had a big impact on Jade every
weekend I get a screen time report and
it used to be horrendously bad my
husband would say it sometimes and he'd
be like oh my god you spend four hours
on your phone a day yeah but now like
during the day I don't have time so my
screen time has I'm proud to say is
between one to two hours a lot less due
to the fact that I'm being a lot more
productive at work congratulations thank
you it's one of the smartest motivators
I've ever seen if your productivity
backslides
you go back to a regular workweek if
you're efficient and effective the
reward is that you get to work less yes
that's a big incentive to not
procrastinate we don't have a lot of
time to procrastinate anymore you just
sort of get in there and get everything
done it's completely changed her work
process now each morning she spends 15
minutes planning her day she color codes
emails and writes lists of priorities
all this helps her complete one task at
a time and move on to the next one
instead of trying to do three things at
once her productivity and her focus have
improved going back to five I don't know
what I would do for the extra day at
work now grocery orders yeah exactly
long breaks are you saying you would
procrastinate if you had a fifth day yes
I probably would now that I'm used to
getting everything done and four I think
I'd have so much extra time so I
probably would procrastinate because
yeah I'd have to fill in the day somehow
you probably don't have the luxury of
just deciding to work fewer hours if
you're an hourly retail employee for
example your income will take a hit but
the shorter work week is a bold
demonstration that it's possible to
manage our work lives differently more
efficiently in any given moment we will
always have dilemmas about whether to
work and what to work on but take it
from Margaret Atwood the tasks you're
putting off isn't always the one you
hate it might be the one you fear the
one that's ultimately the most worth
pursuing
at least that's how it was for The
Handmaid's Tale I did try to write this
more normal novel and it really just did
not work out so that was a signal that I
had to write the batting one or nothing
if you're gonna do the task eventually
you might as well spare yourself the
agony and start it sooner I called that
white rabbit syndrome from Alice in
Wonderland I'm late I'm late I'm late no
time to say hello goodbye none - gotta
go
[Applause]
[Music]
next time on work life this feeling of
being trapped in this system where
you're on like a hamster wheel you know
you're kind of like doing a lot but is
it really changing anything job burnout
seems to be everywhere but it's not
inevitable
work life is hosted by me Adam grant the
show is produced by Ted with transmitter
media our team includes Colin Helms
Greta Cohn dan O'Donnell Constanza
Gerardo Grace Rubenstein Michelle Quint
Angela Chang and Anna Phelan this
episode was produced by Jessica Glaser
our show is mixed by rick quan original
music by hans Dale sue and Alison Layton
Brown add stories produced by pineapple
Street Studios special thanks to our
sponsors accenture veteran Hilton an SI
p for their research thanks to Tim
Mitchell on procrastination max bazerman
Katie milkman and colleagues on want
should selves
Keith Wilcox and colleagues on being
busy Tracy Dumas and Jill Perry Smith on
absorption at work and Bob Boyce on
scheduling writing sessions and thanks
to Candice factor for the amazing
introduction to Margaret
okay so here's the story we were
throwing a party at our house for some
writers and there they were all milling
around and then this young woman who is
about 35 said she was having a heart
attack when I called 911 the paramedics
arrived lumpin II bump up the steps
I love paramedics so in they come and
here's the conversation first paramedic
do you know whose house this is second
paramedic know whose houses at first
paramedic it's Margaret Atwood's house
second paramedic Margaret Atwood is she
still alive
[Laughter]